yo telethon for hip-hop real night u23
already know what it is man bootleg cab
Drayson not sure we are the real
after-party we got a special guest in
the building man French Montana Joe here
la what's up French so bro
for instant entre hey yo first of all yo
congratulations you just told us to
singles officially Platinum's I just
went plan on just now unforgettable man
that record is insane brand you bro how
did the single come to because I you
know I swear I got a crazy pan man yeah
you I mean um somebody played me to rush
into my session then um I thought it was
Jeremiah he played it for me I was like
yo I love this record what we doing just
kept it and so that already had sway on
it when you heard him yeah that's well
know the director that was but the
record was nothing like that though
the record was a totally different song
like the part that I took from the
record was only like a box okay but then
beat the beats which I like I saw the
song come in so it turned into like an
R&B record yo it's a crazy vibe yeah
sure it's actually from super hey could
we get your take - breaking news a
prodigy just passed away from our deep
what yeah how again complications but
because he's at sickle-cell oh wow yeah
man just passed out a story what are
your thoughts man prodigy obviously mobb
deep we grew up on my deep man I just
[ __ ] me up
wow I mean I did a lot of work with him
damn
like for short man you got enjoy it for
sure you got it like a story like a
prodigy story you could share what is a
man like maybe when you first linked up
with him yeah I mean when he first came
home I just went to studio to see him
him was working he just was walking
around like no fresh home but yeah yeah
I got that that that dead prison body
like he working out yeah yeah me and him
and chinks did a record was in the
studio recipes chang-soo
I like I'm saying man like life is short
look both of them both of them gone I'm
still here like I scars made me think
about life man enjoy it while you're
here 100% is crazy here so me call like
three songs and then I'm a blah meaning
of Mia waka was working on a mixtape
with Gucci and we did hell on earth then
I sent it to him you know I thought he
was gonna you know cuz that's real
hip-hop of course you know so you know
and I had started off with send it to
him and he was like yo for really want
to walk on there I'm like I'm like yeah
he was like I was like [ __ ] if you
if you want to do it let's do it no say
but he said like he shot this watch
right and said like you know it's like
really New York you're watching so he
was more like happy that walk was
[ __ ] with a to lie down real hip hop
touch people they don't say that
definite one of the stories right there
and he arrested peace man merciful peace
prodigy-man we're gonna miss you that's
a legend man like that's a man yo so
Brooklyn that new French uh you also
tweeted that yo max beyond that Summer
Jam stage you do that in the atmosphere
max be staying like ten minutes away
from Summer Jam so I thought gonna pull
it off you'd be able to kind of pull it
off get the permission situated just in
and out don't say heaven God's this and
that how close was that from happening
it was I mean it wasn't close and there
wasn't no so it was like that way we'll
get back to you we were like not we're
not doing it what's the update with max
P Bona Bona good side he'll my next
single me it's me him in the weekend oh
wow that's a wave right there well and
produced by Harry fraud and one of my
favorite producers who you've been
working with just a war yeah so produced
by Harry fraud meeting having max the
weekend we just shot the video for last
week you know that's a movie right there
man helps us coming out real soon shout
out to every frogman yeah
what is kind of like the feeling been
since you you know obviously for people
who don't know man press has been in
this for years he's been living a
mixtape thing for years um now you're
like a global icon man this new record I
feel like like we were just talking Dre
was saying it's like a worldly vibe you
know what I'm saying do you feel the
difference you know with this new record
as opposed to like like a pop debt which
is probably the most most successful
single prior to this yeah at the strip
club record something Cimino was it do
you feel the difference vibe when you
out with the people and hear it in the
club um I just feel growth man and I
feel like with this record had taught me
that um you got it you got to know what
you you got to know what you're capable
of like i lobby with torments wasn't
gonna be a hobby when I'm saying this
and that but I knew I knew deep down in
my heart this record was it so I fought
for this record like five months to get
it because they belong to somebody else
then after that it was a had came out
before leaf then I had say catch up to
it which happens everybody of course
happened to the weekend with the hills
you know some people just you know
that's what they do but for me to
believe and for us to get it where it's
going and now it's already platinum in a
month and a half
100 million views on VEVO already 200
million Spotify being like it's like
it's a whole different kind of record I
told French I knew is gonna be some
because he personally out of the party
DJ's like need you to play this and then
somebody else came was like I need you
to play this about third times like all
right there's got to be some cuz after
the third person and friends tell me
it's going to be some I played it I
think I played it three times the Rope
yeah first time it also about
everybody's a trade I survived
fresh how's the dance come to be though
dances me my brother belly because after
dance
I mean I'm obviously Caucasian so I
can't dance for [ __ ] yeah but that
doesn't even been exactly that's why I
appreciate it yeah I think I have to say
that real I also want to know what made
you want to shoot the video in Africa um
I want I want to give back I want to use
my platform to give back man I mean I'm
from there so I lived in 13 years and
plus I mean when I went there to shoot
the video with these kids I wanted to
capture them in their own environment
and when I went there just happen to see
poverty and I wanted to help those
answer we almost done building this
hospital over there you know I see a lot
people take culture before never give
back so I want to give back
tersteeg yo uh so the last album with
absolutely no mac and cheese for like it
was it was very confusing situation
Elite yeah I was changing labels okay
and when I changed the labels I set a
date that's what I set a date that I was
just leaked
no saying when it's supposed to come out
but it wasn't nobody for it was just it
was meant to happen like that I guess
God had unforgettable things about to
have a hundred percent man you know but
regardless to that you know both um
lockjaw and platinum and no chaperone
plan yo like I was crazy and the record
with Nas and Kanye was yeah I mean I
have such a great album immaculate you
know Sam but but I'm just I'm just happy
that we passed through that stage and
I'm saying I mean I want triple platinum
on singles on Apple that never came out
that's that's like good we shout out
French too because he is living proof I
want to hear nothing more about a
Kardashian curse this is
it's bright out here yes thrive yeah
here's the bug the cleric Kardashian
Kurt myth right there
shout out to the homie French Montana
about yo so you said the next singles
got weekend and Max be honor which is
crazy
yeah yeah for sure when we're gonna get
that on real soon real real soon and
then Alan we got our album early real
soon real soon
no I'm not doing that long haul there's
gonna come bomb to contrive yeah you
know talk about your relationship with
them we you know with that with the EXO
camp man I don't even be involved with
the wall shots at home to the weekend he
just um gave 100,000 to the hospital
damn we building and um and in half
Raqqah shot - mama hope and global
citizen
they're not private over the
organization that's helping us through
the whole thing and we going on tour
together me we're doing a couple days in
the States
we're doing Canada and we're doing
Australia that's all set man
it's gonna be here that's going to be
Mexico voice yo obviously a big recipe
so out to change drugs shown here on
intro Mahalo
oh that's dope so we got braids so you
got Mac to be inching calm down yeah
that's gonna be that's gonna be crazy
man shot to chinks but who's next up
with coke boys man right now is just
mild you just focus on others from so
now when you look into that I ain't mad
at that man French Montana in the
building or unforgettable your friends
we gotta know when you get to LA though
what is like the one or two places that
you have to go every time you come to LA
where a bullet Kevin's nostril planner
this little bird that's why you here
right now my nose you already know you
still got the monkey yeah of course he
was father right now family reunion
who's his father oh I'm as father than
la is that bugs
yeah Oh buzz this is pop yeah yeah you
know first time I ever met Buster's I'm
only mother's house yeah I walk in and
God mother-in-law his monkey is jacking
off in the old cage with a portable DVD
player but hey Kuryakin somebody hunts
in the house watching Curious George
cartoons while touching themselves like
I couldn't make that [ __ ] up man
shoutout to French Montana we appreciate
you checking in Matthew man let's get
into this new single Oh for Ally email
is over
I live without what I was your boyfriend
my antenna is the hottest wreck in the
country right now it's went platinum
today how that's your boy you ever know
who hit a nice home for hip-hop real
92.3 let's go